مراسله الجزيره كارمن جهدار كما ينضم
الينا من ميكو لايف مراسل الجزيره تامر
الصمادي ابدا مع كتامر واخر المعلومات
لديك حول الوضع في بخموت وايضا اخر
التصريحات والمواقف الاوكرانيه في هذا
الشان
نعم سهام لم اسمع السؤال جيدا هنالك تقطع
في الصوت لكن التطور الجديد هو الحديث
الذي اطلقه الرئيس زيلينسكي قبل قليل
عندما كان يرد على احد الصحفيين عن مصير
اباخ موت توقعنا عندما قال بان باخمه باتت
الان في قلوب الاوكرانيين ان الصفحه قد
طويت صفحه المدينه قط طويت وقضيت الامر
بعد اشهر طويله ثقيله من القتال بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طول محاور
المدينه لكن عدنا مره اخرى الى ذات الجدل
والى ذات الروايات المتناقضه والمتباعده
قبل قليل فقط خرج السكرتير الصحفي في
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ليقول ويوضح بان تصريح
الرئيس الاوكراني فهم خطا هو كان يقصد
وفقا لقوله بان المدينه في قلوب
الاوكرانيين وانها باتت مدمره بالكامل
وانها تحولت الى اطلال لكن الرئيس قال لا
وكان يقول لا بان القوات الروسيه لا تسيطر
على كامل المدينه حتى هذه اللحظه وفي
الحقيقه هذا التصريح يتقاطع مع تصريح اخرى
اخر عفوا تصريحات اخرى
لهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه صباح اليوم التي
تحدثت بشكل واضح في بيانها الصباحي بان
القتال لا زال عنيفا شرسا بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه في باغموت وان القوات
تقاتل وهو ايضا يقترب من ذات التصريح الذي
اشارت الي نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
مساء يوم امس عندما قالت بان الوضع صعب في
باقي اقرت بصعوبه الوضع في باقمه لكنها
اشارت الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا زالت
تسيطر على العديد من المنشات الصناعيه
وبنيه التحتيه في مناطق غرب ضخمه وهي
المناطق التي كانت تسيطر عليها حتى يوم
امس وحتى هذه اللحظه وفقا للقياده الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه القوات الاوكرانيه المتحدث
باسم القياده الشرقيه الاوكرانيه شريفاتي
ظهر على شاشه الجزيره الليله الماضيه وقال
بشكل واضح بان القوات الاوكرانيه لم تنس
تتواجد في مواقعها وانها تقاتل وان القتال
سيظل متواصلا وشكك في روايه مالك شركه
باجنر وقال باننا اعتدنا على مثل هذا
الاعلان المتكرر للجانب الروسي وتحديدا
باقنر بالسيطره على باق موت وقال بان
القوات الاوكرانيه ستعمل على السيطره
وستعمل على تكبيد القوات الخاصه باجنر
مزيد من الخسائر في المدينه وقال ايضا انه
في حال انسحبت القوات الاوكرانيه من قلب
المدينه باكموت ومن الاطراف الغربيه الى
خارج باق موت فانها ستعمل على تطويق
المدينه وبالتالي محاصره قوات باجنر
والقوات الروسيه لكن في الحقيقه سهام اذا
سلمنا جدلا بان رئيس الاوكراني كان يقصد
خلال الساعه الاخيره بان
باخمه سقطت بشكل كامل في يد القوات
الروسيه فهذا لا يعني ان القوات الروسيه
عفوا ستتقدم بين ليلى وضحاها باتجاه
المدينه اكراماتورس شرقي الوضع وفقا
للروايه الاوكرانيه
للتصريحات المتتاليه للقيادات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه سيكون صعب وصعب للغايه لا سيما
ان باخموت ونتحدث عن منطقه صغيره بلده
صغيره يعني القتال فيها بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه متواصل منذ ثمانيه
اشهر بعد لا توجد كراماتورسك وانما منطقه
تشاسفيار هذه المنطقه جغرافيا مهمه للغايه
وترجح قليلا الكفه الاوكرانيه لانها منطقه
مرتفعه عن باخمت وخلف تشافيار هنالك
العديد من القرى الصغيره والمسافه بين
باخمت وبين كراماتورس يعني زين العابدين
اكثر من 60 كيلو مترا والقوات الاوكرانيه
تقول بان لديها خطوط دفاع طويله وقويه وان
القتال الذي استمر في باقمه ثمانيه اشهر
قد يستمر لاشهر اطول واطول وصولا الى
كروماتورسك